[Musique]
visiblement il ya problème de génériques
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire marlène schiappa ministre
délégué à la citoyenneté réactive la
lutte contre les sectes qui était tombé
en désuétude
elle a nommé une magistrate à la tête de
la miviludes la mission
interministérielle de vigilance et de
lutte contre les dérives sectaires qui
n'avait plus de président depuis deux
ans et s'est fait remettre un état des
lieux des nouvelles tendances sectaire
qu'elle a commenté dans une interview
dans l'umps dans le viseur
en plus des témoins de jéhovah ou des
chrétiens évangélistes il ya désormais
les crudivores les masculinistes les
anti vaccins les complotistes anti 5g la
mouvance qua none les survivalistes 500
groupes en tout contre lesquelles la
ministre a décidé de nous protéger en
priorité
alors pour en débattre nous avons invité
arnaud esquerre qui est sociologue
chargé de recherche cnrs directeur de
l'institut de recherche
interdisciplinaire sur les enjeux
sociaux vous êtes l'auteur de la
manipulation mentale sociologie des
sectes en france paru chez fayard en
la miviludes la mission
interministérielle de vigilance et de
lutte contre les dérives sectaires que
l'on compte que l'on croyait enterrée
renaît de ses cendres faut-il s'en
féliciter je sais pas s'il faut s'en
féliciter c'est simplement en tout cas
la continuité d'une une action menée
depuis les pouvoirs publics depuis les
années depuis les années 80 et la
modification d'un de la manière dont on
conçoit les sectes depuis les années 70
donc je crois que ça s'inscrit
simplement dans la continuité de
l'action de l'état et des pouvoirs
publics
admirez lit vous êtes historienne
professeur honoraire à l'université de
bruxelles spécialisé dans l'histoire des
religions et des minorités vous êtes
l'auteur de les trouvères tu as la secte
des adversaires des sectes paru dans la
collection cartier libre en 1990
en 1997 le retour de la la lutte contre
les sectes c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
vous un pas du tout parce que ça fait de
nombreuses années que je plaide pour la
suppression de la miviludes et de son
équivalent belge ainsi que de ses
associations jean rapp fille à dif et
cetera qui ont pour objet d'être de
grands inquisiteurs qui disent quelles
sont les bonnes religion qui ont droit à
des subsides comme en alsace lorraine
comme en belgique et les autres les
méchantes les mauvaises qui doivent être
persécutés donc c'est une ingérence du
pouvoir politique dans la religion est
aujourd'hui nous voyons de manière
caricaturale
mme adams qui a pas intervenir en temps
vous voyez nous tenons la situation bien
en main nous les politiques nous vous
protégeons contre tous ces méchants
donc je trouve que c'est une très
mauvaise nouvelle pour la liberté de
pensée pour la liberté de religion
charline delporte vous êtes la
présidente du centre national
d'accompagnement familial et de
formation face à l'emprise sectaire
le café est ce cela fait une trentaine
d'années après que votre fille a rejoint
les témoins de jéhovah que vous êtes
engagés dans la lutte contre les sectes
l adf y à la confédération nationale des
victimes de l'organisation des témoins
de jéhovah est maintenant à la tête du
café est ce que vous avez fondé en 2014
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour vous la
réactivation de la miviludes et bien sûr
cher monsieur ben bien sûr que je suis
ravi que l'on puisse reparler du secteur
s'est pas pendant parlait plus mais
c'est vrai que depuis maintenant une
trentaine d'années que je suis bénévole
dans ces centres et sur le fait secteur
est bien j'étais ravie qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons ce rapport de 22 pages et que
l'on pourra continuer à accueillir dans
notre centre qui est aujourd'hui le café
et moi en tant que présidente nationale
mais basel
accueillir ces familles qui viennent
nous raconter une histoire douloureuse
n'ont pas de secte on va tout de suite
abandonné le mot secte 1 ça c'est d'un
autre temps on va simplement parlé d'
emprise sectaire d'un mouvements à
caractère sectaire avec des effets
dommageables et des pratiques qui sont
contraires aux lois de la république et
notre mission c'est d'accompagner ces
personnes en leur tendant la main et en
expliquant ce qui leur arrive parce
qu'ils ont été de bonne foi manipuler et
miss vous emprise et je suis ravie
aujourd'hui que notre ministre délégué
madame marlène schiappa eh bien on
revoit tout cela parce qu en effet
aujourd'hui ça a explosé
alors on va d'abord commencer par dire
secte non pas secte aussi bien
juridiquement en france en tout cas le
mot secte ne veut plus rien dire du tout
parce que ici parce que si vous êtes
d'accord
on en reparlera raphaël liogier vous
vous êtes philosophe et sio sociologue
professeur de sociologie à sciences po
aix en provence vous enseigne également
à paris au collège de philosophie êtes
l'auteur de souci de soi conscience du
monde qui était paru chez armand colin
en 2012 il y était question du sujet qui
nous intéresse ce soir est votre dernier
livre coécrit avec dominique costa da
est un manifeste métaphysique paru aux
liens qui libèrent
bonne nouvelle ou mauvaise nouvelle la
réactivation de la miviludes
j'ai bien peur très clairement que ce
soit une mauvaise nouvelle parce que
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle aussi
parlent pour l'état de notre société et
en particulier du champ politique parce
que ce que j'ai pu constater moi dans
mes recherches en dehors de leurs
analyses cliniques de ce que sont
certains mouvements qui peuvent être des
mouvements des mouvements durs des
mouvements même d'emprise mentale en
dehors de ça je crois que la lutte
contre les sectes en france c'est le
prétexte à une lutte idéologique d'une
part et d'autre part c'est une fabrique
d'unanimité à dire tout le champ
politique se porte mal quand on arrive
plus par exemple la veille d'une
élection
suivez mon regard
à à créer de l'unanimité bien on a
toujours les sacs parce que les sacs des
passes en quelque sorte c'est un
problème trans partisan où on est sûr de
fabriquer dans l'unanimisme et souvent
sur le domaine des victimes en réalité
sur le domaine des victimes parce que on
fait fi de l'analyse clinique qu'il
faudrait faire qui se rapporte à ce qui
se passe dans notre société puisque les
sexes ne sont rien d'autre que la
caricature où j'allais dire le miroir
grossissant de transformation sociale
notre propre narration de nos propres
notre croyance et c'est ça qu'il
faudrait analyser mais on fait
exactement le contraire en france on
cherche fabriqué il faut savoir que la
lutte contre les sectes
c'est une spécificité française qui nous
a valu d'ores et déjà d'être condamnée
par la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme d'être critiqué l onu pour notre
restrictions à la liberté religieuse
c'est une politique publique et à ce
titre certains trouvent qu'elle est en
contradiction avec la laïcité qui
garantit la tolérance religieuse et la
neutralité de l'état
or là avec la lutte contre les sectes
qui est devenue depuis la lutte contre
les dérives sectaires parce que
justement c'était contraire à la laïcité
l'état se mêle des croyances des
citoyens ça ne pose pas de problème ça
ne vous pose pas de problème arnaud
esquerre à arnaud nous en part de là
ça y est ici non mais écoutez le la
question en fait c'est que le mot secte
et d'ailleurs on l'a entendu là avec les
différents les différents intervenants
il a une histoire une histoire assez
ancien il a une particularité c'est
qu'il est toujours sous forme
d'accusation c'est à dire vous n'avez
jamais un groupe qui revendique être une
secte c'est toujours quelqu'un d'autre
qui accuse un autre groupe d'être une
secte ou de dérives sectaires et ça
cette histoire à les anciennes si vous
regardez pendant la révolution française
ont désigné des cercles au 19e siècle
ont désigné des sectes tout au long du
xxème siècle on a désigné des sectes
simplement à chaque fois le ski est
désigné par secte n'est pas du tout les
mêmes groupes donc au 19e siècle
c'est depuis l'église catholique en
france qui a les sectes sont désignés et
les sectes ça va être la secte franc
maçonne par exemple est en fête
jusqu'aux années 70 les sectes sont
désignés principalement depuis le
catholicisme en france donc ce qui est
désigné ce sont des groupes qui sont en
rupture avec le dogme catholique
mais ce qui se passe à partir des années
70 si vous avez des associations de
victimes qui se constitue qui engage
ensuite les pouvoirs publics dans la
lutte contre les sectes à partir des
années 80 est de plus en plus dans les
années 90 qui est un grand moment en
fait où il va y avoir une mobilisation
des pouvoirs publics contre les sectes
or si vous engagez les pouvoirs publics
et des associations de victimes pour
lutter contre les sectes vous modifier
complètement la manière dont vous les
désigner ça ne peut plus être par
rapport à un dogme religieux donc comme
le faisait l'église catholique mais ça
va être par rapport à autre chose et
c'est à ce moment là seulement qu
apparaît l'idée en tout cas reprises par
les pouvoirs publics que la secte a
quelque chose à avoir avec la
manipulation mentale l'emprise sectaire
et à ce moment là vous étendez
complètement les groupes désignés dont
vous avez des groupes qui peuvent être
pas du tout religieux vous avez des
groupes qui vont être tournés vers le
des aspects qui sont davantage liés à la
sexualité à l'écologie
à l'environnement tout un tas de groupes
qui se retrouvent désigné y compris des
groupes qui existait en fait
spiritualiste depuis le début du 20e
siècle où la fin du 19e siècle qui tout
d'un coup se trouve qualifié de secte
dans le rapport de 2,95 et en fait c'est
ça qui se sait ce qui se passe et qu'on
voit encore aujourd'hui je rappelle que
quand il ya eu au début des années 2000
la question de la réglementation du
titre de psychothérapeute dont on
pensait en fait qu'il était utilisée de
manière abusive
l'argument qui était avancée était aussi
déjà la question des sacs c'était pour
lutter contre les sectes qu'on voulait
réglementer le titre de psychothérapeute
donc voyez con con étant complètement le
spectre et qu'on a quitté en fait la
manière dont les les sectes étaient
désignés où les emprises secteur était
et est qualifiée depuis
enfin juste jusqu'au jusqu'aux années
soixante dix 70 4 donc s'il se passe
aujourd'hui si vous voulez c'est on est
tout à fait dans la continuité de de ce
type d'actions mises en place depuis les
années 80 on va dire
et le fait qu'on désigne un grand nombre
enfin qu'on dise voilà qu'il ya beaucoup
de 2 sec qui a 500 c'est clair comme le
disait marines à part ça ça a toujours
été si vous voulez dans la dénonciation
des sectes à par l'église catholique qui
dénonçait voilà de manière très
importante au xixème siècle la secte dit
maçonnique
et puis à la fin du 19ème une inquiétude
qui était lié aux anarchistes qui
étaient eux mêmes désignées comme des
sectes la secte anarchiste il ya un
livre d'un sociologue qui s'appelle
gabriel tarde qui est sur les sectes et
qui vise les sectes qui dans le calme et
des anarchistes parce que justement lui
prend un point d'appliquer la suggestion
c'est à dire un peu l'équivalent de la
manipulation mentale mais sinon vous
avez tout le temps plein de sectes qui
sont désignés l'abbé grégoire qui a fait
un grand dictionnaire des sectes au
début du 19e siècle
il désigne un très grand nombre de sacs
on s'inquiète jamais seulement d'une
secte on s'inquiète en fait d'une
multitude de sectes et donc on est dans
un discours je dirais assez classique et
assez assez balisé qui voilà qui est qui
qui ce qui ce qui se perpétue si je peux
dire aujourd'hui
alors anne morelli c'est vrai qu'il n'ya
pas que des religions ou
de derrière des pseudo religion qui sont
désignés il ya des thérapies
alternatives des groupes paramilitaires
des complotistes n'est néanmoins c'est
presque dire arnaud esquerre ça peut te
frapper aussi bien donc les les
francs-maçons que autre chose notre
notre énergie aux sectes alors le
problème c'est qu'il n'ya pas de
définition possible de secte j'ai fait
partie de la commission parlementaire en
belgique qui s'est penché sur ce sujet
et en fait elle avait demandé à quatre
professeurs de différentes universités
francophones comme flamands de venir
expliquer quelle était la différence
entre une secte est une religion et sans
nous concerter on a tous dit la même
chose c'est impossible parce que il n'ya
pas de critères qui permettent de mettre
d'un côté les bons d'un côté les
méchants et par exemple ce qui est
concerne une constitue ce qui est
considéré comme une secte dans un pays
peut être considérée comme une grande
religion tout à fait honorable dans un
autre je prends l'exemple des mormons
si vous êtes né dans l'état de utah vous
allez considérer que c'est la normalité
de la religion d'être mouvement mais en
belgique peut-être en france si les
mormons ont été surveillés par ces
associations pas ses pouvoirs publics
comme la rive sud et c'est donc d'un
côté à l'autre de la frontière on peut
être considérés comme bons mauvais et
nous avons en belgique un exemple tout à
fait caricatural parce que sont les
écoles steiner
alors les écoles steiner sont considérés
du côté francophone de la belgique
pourtant nous sommes un tout petit pays
du côté francophone comme une secte et
on a donné aux enfants la ministre de
l'éducation a donné un certain moment
aux enfants des écoles des petits
dépliants
gare aux gourous disant de se méfier des
stein est et de l'autre côté du côté
flamand et bien les écoles steiner
sont subventionnés par le pouvoir les
pouvoirs publics dont qu' il est
impossible de décider qui est une secte
et qui est une religion l'homéopathe il
va vous dire qu'il est un médecin très
sérieux mais ses collègues vont
considérer que c'est une secte et je
pense que c'est dans cette difficulté
que on voit exactement que c'est le
pouvoir politique qui désigne qui est
une bonne religion et qui est une secte
le pouvoir politique a le pouvoir de
décider ce qu'ils vont être subsidiés ou
ceux qui vont être persécutés au
contraire et moi je ne suis d'aucun de
ses mouvements mais je trouve assez
dramatique compère de beaucoup de temps
de fonctionnaires et d'argent à
persécuter des gens comme l'armée du
salut les adventistes du septième jour
où même les témoins de jéhovah
je pense qu'il ya des urgences qui sont
différentes et je pense que tout ce
temps et ce personnel qui a été consacré
à cela aurait mieux fait d'être consacré
véritablement à la lutte contre des
ennemis de la démocratie contre les
terroristes entre guillemets j'allais
une belle porte qu'est ce que vous
répondez and molly l'un coûté au risque
de vous décevoir chère madame je veux
pas qu'on a entre vous et moi c'est
compliqué je ne veux pas vous blesser ni
je crois que j'ai trois ya trois
sociologues deux des religions est un
qu'il est pas donc je voudrais pas vous
décevoir mais d'abord je ne sais pas ce
que je fais la main si vous voulez vous
défendez la lutte contre les sectes ou
contre les dérives sectaires ou la
miviludes à ce moment là monsieur moi si
je ne veux pas blesser cgc personnes
ils ont une histoire ce sont des
sociologues
icogne alors la lys
voir je les connais bien puisque pour ma
culture générale quelquefois je vais les
écouter
mais ici je tiens donc à mon poste à 7
ce bénévolat et depuis près de 30 ans je
suis une écoutante et je suis devenu
président il ya 28 ans mais justement
d'un si nous expliquez vous admirez les
crises et charline delporte vous pouvez
nous expliquer embauché par exemple les
témoins de jéhovah dont vous avez l'air
d'avoir souffert personnellement dans
votre famille je vous hais les témoins
de jéhovah ou les chrétiens évangéliques
son nom ne sont pas des religions comme
les autres mais écoutez d'abord on va
prendre on va essayer ou simplement et
en france en tout cas on a une laïcité
moi je parle la france parce que la
laïcité en france dit bien que tout
croyant c'est tolérable et respectable
et que la liberté de conscience est tout
à fait respectable également et qu'on a
le droit de croire à tout ce que l'on
veut rappelons la laïcité elle est très
sain alors pour moi les témoins de
jéhovah ou les adventices tous les
évangéliques ou je ne sais pas quoi
ces associations en règle générale de
qui se met derrière des associations loi
moi j'ai rien à dire du moment qu'ils ne
sont pas contraires aux lois de la
république
par contre là où j'interviens en tant
que présidente et bien c'est quand ces
organisations ici c'est simple vous
savez c'est d'une grande simplicité moi
c'est quand on vient dans notre centre
et convient c'est souvent la famille qui
viennent nous raconter une histoire
douloureuse depuis que mon mari mon
enfant ma famille ou un des membres un
être cher est entré dans ce groupe je le
trouve plus pareil il a plus les mêmes
combats il a des pratiques religieuses
différentes mais surtout il a aussi des
effets dommageables
il ne vit plus avec nous ils se séparent
n'y a donc là on se rend compte et là
non plus je n'ai aucun mérite c'est la
famille qui vient nous raconter une
histoire douloureuse
alors on n'est pas là pour leur dire bah
écoutez c'est du religieux
allez voir qui vous voulez non ma
mission voix c'est d'écouter et de voir
si derrière ça parce qu'il faut quand
même le dire depuis quand même
maintenant plus de 28 ans et 30 ans nous
savons nous avons derrière nous des
critères de dangerosité puisqu'on a eu
un rapport en france 1995 où on parlait
justement de définir un mouvement
sectaire et c'est vrai qu'on disait
secte ne peut rien dire par cette
définition est au contraire ce rapport
de 95,6 et bien il ya en effet des
critères de dangerosité
quand quelqu'un est une déstabilisation
mentale quand quelqu'un entre dans un
mouvement à caractère sectaire
je n'emploie pas le mot secte et il a un
processus
donc le processus de je dirais
d'adhésion de conditionnement de rupture
familiale de contractualisation pour le
groupe tout en laissant tomber
je dirais tout ses centres d'intérêts ça
c'est la mission pour moi en tout cas
c'est ça une emprise sectaire et c'est
comme ça que je la lis mais avec la
famille et la famille est perdue parce
qu'elles ne parlent plus le même langage
elle fréquente un groupe alors religieux
pas religieux moi j'en ai rien à faire
mais tout ce que je sais c'est que en
règle générale il ya toujours de la
croyance et de la doctrine une idéologie
en effet qui peut pour certains et
peut-être les sociologues j'ai devant
moi
et bien c'est une idéologie ce tout ce
que vous voulez moi je ne vais pas aller
chercher les mouvements à caractère
sectaire
on vient chez nous nous en parler geocam
eric vous voyez et à partir de ça à
partir de ce constat là et avec ce
rapport de que de 1995 que j'ai encore
toujours en 2021
il y en a eu
second en 2009 fait par philippe jean
parquet qui était jean philippe parquet
non philippe jean parquet psychiatre et
qui lui parlait également d'emprise et
les comportements qui changeait ces
personnes ils ont été de bonne foi
manipuler bien souvent sur une croyance
donc je dis tout à l'heure les croyances
soient absolument tolérable si elles
sont pas contraires aux lois de la
république
nous on ne voit et je crois que les
sociologues que j'ai devant moi ne voit
que cette partie là mais ne voit pas
l'arrière boutique et l'effet terrifiant
que font vivre ces leaders à caractère
sectaire qui eux par contre et ça je ne
pourrai jamais un pas en arrière sur ce
genre de personnage est bien sont des
pervers manipulateur qui vont mettre
sous emprise et qu'ils vont tout
doucettement et bien changer le projet
de cette personne qui de bonne foi été
manipulée pour le mettre sous ce projet
son projet à lui pour qu'il devienne au
bout du parcours un esclave heureux et
c'est pas moi qui ai dit vous parliez
des témoins de jéhovah tout à l'heure et
bien chez les témoins de jéhovah une
fois que tu es bien reconstruit pour les
témoins de jéhovah et les lois de
jéhovah moi je les connais pas je
connais que les lois de la république et
bien les lois de j'aurais dû bien tu
seras un esclave fidèles et avisé mais
ronnie bird de la scientologie disent eh
bien je ferai de vous des esclaves
heureux alors je sais pas si ces
sociologues ont lu jusqu'au bout les
ouvrages de ces mouvements-là et de ces
gens là moi je vais pas parler de canaux
2d des catholiques et d'autres choses
moi je parle de ce que je vis dans ce
centre depuis un jeu je n'étais rocha
l'une d'elles bord d'un porte juste pour
que l morelli vous veut vous répondre
elle morelli oui alors moi je ne néglige
pas du tout la souffrance des parents
j'ai moi-même quatre enfants je les ai
élevés dans la laïcité je serais
consterné quand deux de mes enfants dit
je veux devenir petites soeurs de
l'assomption
ou bien je veux devenir dominicaine
je veux devenir parce que je considérais
que mon éducation est raté et variés de
la sépare de la souffrance des parents
quand ils voient que leurs enfants
peuvent plus manger avec eux etc
eh bien c'est la souffrance dit que les
parents ont aujourd'hui lorsqu'un de
leurs enfants devient weygand et qu' il
les regarde avec un grand dégoût manger
le poulet du dimanche
alors vous disiez que les témoins de
jéhovah et je n'en suis pas rassurez
vous met au bord de leur groupe les gens
qui ont été excommuniés de l'heure de
leur salle des témoins de jéhovah et
bien deux prend-il leurs ordres eh bien
ils les prennent de la bible et c'est
paul dans la première épître aux
corinthiens 5 9 11 qui dit il ne faut
plus de relation avec un frère qui est
devenu idolâtre cupide un public rap
rapaces ivrogne et cetera
même pas pour prendre un repas ensemble
et ses agents dont la deuxième épître
dit la même chose ne le recevrait pas
chez vous abstenez vous de le saluer
celui qui le salut participent à ces
oeuvres mauvaise
alors vous savez si vous voulez
interdire la bible je crois que vous
aurez beaucoup de
mais ce contient la souffrance des
parents et si demain une de mes fils
mais à se voiler et à devenir musulmane
ce sera pour moi un échec de mon
éducation et je peux comprendre qu'il y
ait des parents qu'ils souffrent de ça
mais il ne faut pas pour autant
moyer le la liberté religieuse et la
possibilité d'exercer sa liberté de
conscience jcem raphaël liogier veut
dire un mot juste dit le vide parce
qu'on fait une pause dans une musique
rock est longue et les verts appellent
non non ce que je voulais dire c'est que
comme le comme le disait arnaud esquerre
c'est indissociable de l'histoire de
france et l'histoire du catholicisme et
en particulier la sape a été dit mais
l'histoire
2 du catholicisme français face au
protestantisme et est ce que max weber à
l'époque déjà après a appelé les sectes
protestantes et c'était pas péjoratif
lorsqu'il parlait de sexe parce que on
peut donner une définition de sectes
assez facilement mais pas de secte
dangereuse c'est ça qui est difficile à
définir une secte c'est très simple en
fait
une 7,6 un groupe de gens qui décident
de vivre en général de façon différente
du reste de la société en fonction d'une
doctrine d'une idée quelle qu'elle soit
on pascal parler de la sec des
épicuriens ont parlé la sec des
sceptiques etc
c'est ça la question c'est là le rapport
à la dangerosité or le rapport à la
dangerosité
il est défini aujourd'hui en france de
façon j'allais dire depuis effectivement
qu'il 19e 20e siècle et depuis les
années 80 en particulier en 84 en
particulier avec le rapport rien il est
dit
il est défini de façon hégémonique il
est défini de façon hégémonique par les
victimes
alors je crois que l'état a fini par
instrumentaliser les victimes au
détriment même des victimes parce que si
on voulait être efficace
même dans la lutte contre les sectes
finalement ça ne saurait que des sectes
est réellement dangereuse ça serait
moins difficile qu'on le croit seulement
ça créerait pas de l'unanimisme de
l'unanimisme politique je pourrai plus
tard dans l'émission expliquer pourquoi
et comment
mais lorsqu'on fait confiance uniquement
aux associations victime et les deux
grandes associations victime qui
existait c'était le centre gilles corre
qui était plutôt les laïcistes
idéologique du raté et c'est qu'ils
voulaient faire prévaloir leur idéologie
puis face à sarah vit l'unadfi l'union
nationale des associations de défense
des familles et de l'individu qu'on
trouvait plutôt au début du mois chez
les catholiques eux pour la défense des
familles de l'enseignement privé sous
contrat et c est en fait progressivement
il ya eu unification des deux pourquoi
parce que dans un sens parce que dans un
sens la laïcité n'est pas arrivé à se
départir structurellement de son espèce
de catholicisme de son désir d'une
grâce à l'immunité d'uniformiser aux
quelque sorte je vous interromps
auxquels on fait une pause et on revient
sur ce sujet juste après la crise
sanitaire pourrait creuser encore un peu
plus les inégalités entre les plus
riches et les plus pauvres il ya un
million de pauvres en plus on est passé
de 9 à 10 millions de pauvres
on a 20 % des français qui ne mangent
pas à leur faim nous ne sommes pas en
france on a l'impression d'être en train
de passer dans un pays du tiers-monde le
problème il est bien en amont il est
depuis que les banques centrales
intrigues de l'argent et quand elle
imprime de l'argent en fait ça ne va pas
dans l'économie réelle
ça va juste sur les marchés financiers
la cause de la paupérisation de la
france de la tiers-mondisation sur les
90 s'engage si la destruction de
l'industrie française réindustrialiser
c'est pas juste en claquant des doigts
vous faites revenir les sociétés d'abord
il faut changer complètement tout c'est
à dire tout ce qui les a fait partir il
ya une débauche d'argent qu'on met sur
le sur la table sans se préoccuper de
savoir qui au final va payer au final
c'est toujours les mêmes les dindons de
la farce c'est toujours les mêmes vers
qui on va se tourner pour aller payer la
note
jordan barre de la et marion maréchal-le
pen qui dénonce cette censure pour eux
facebook menaçant fait de publier des
pages de soutien au mouvement génération
identitaire il faut en finir avec cette
dérive dégâts femmes il faut rappeler la
primauté du droit français sur le
territoire national les pouvoirs publics
en france et dans d'autres pays sont un
peu tétanisé face aux géants du
numérique
moi j'ai eu l'occasion il ya quelques il
ya deux ans au parlement européen d'
interpeller
mark zuckerberg le pdg de facebook sur
cette question il avait d'ailleurs
répondu de manière très alambiquée mais
je crois que ça nécessite maintenant que
les pouvoirs publics se saisissent du
sujet il défend la libre expression et
s'ils ne le font pas et bien compris
[Musique]
reprend ce débat contrôlé sur la lutte
contre les sectes avec arnaud esquerre
qui est sociologue c'est l'auteur de la
manipulation mentale sociologie des
sectes en france il ya également anne
morelli qu'est l'auteur de lettres
ouvertes à la secte des adversaires des
sectes
il y à charline delporte qui est la
présidente du centre d'accompagnement
familial et de formation face à
l'emprise sectaire et raphaël liogier
qui est philosophe et sociologue
professeur universitaire est l'auteur
d'un manifeste métaphysique qui vient de
paraître aux liens qui libèrent alors on
l'a dit la la lutte contre les sectes ou
plutôt contre les dérives sectaires
parce que ce serait contraire à la
laïcité de lutter contre les sectes
alors on lutte contre les dérives
sectaires était un peu tombé en
désuétude
on luttait contre l'islamisme on en
avait oublié de lutter contre les sectes
et puis ça vient d'être réactivée par
marlène schiappa et des 173 secte listé
en 1995 au moment où on crée la
miviludes
on est passé à 500 aujourd'hui des
petits groupes a dit marlène schiappa
dans lequel on trouve alors on a dit les
témoins de jéhovah ou les chrétiens
évangélistes ça c'est des gros groupes
et puis des petits groupes c'est à dire
des masculinistes des survivalistes des
des antilles 5g des crudivore voilà ce
sont aujourd'hui les sectes contre
lesquels marlène schiappa a entrepris de
lutter vous l'avez dit arnaud esquerre
ça ne date pas d'hier on a toujours
ajouter aux religions qu'on voulait
combattre les thérapies alternatives les
modes de vie communautaire qui sont au
fond assimilé à du séparatisme
en fait ma n ya pas là on a nous
annonçant le programme
elles continuent de lutter contre les
séparatismes enfin tel que c'est tel que
ces formules et elle elle propose de
lutter activement contre des groupes qui
sont des groupes minoritaires en
reprenant si vous l'expression secte
elle a l'idée en fait de s'appuyer sur
quelque chose qui a été mis en place
dans les années en termes de disco dans
les années voilà 70 80 qui était l'idée
en fait qu'une secte était totalitaire
donc si ça va au fond contre la
démocratie et donc après quand on dit
dérives sectaires il yal il ya cette
idée derrière effectivement qu'on passe
sur l'idée d'emprise et avec l'idée de
totalitariste contre la démocratie donc
c'est ça qu'elle qu'elle réutilise ce
que ce que je voudrais souligner c'est
que par ailleurs effectivement il peut y
avoir il ya de la souffrance exprimée
par les proches de qui ont quelqu'un qui
va ou qui consiste dans un groupe tu es
qualifie de sek et qui a des instruments
dont on n'a pas parlé là et qui sont
quand même très important et qui sont
les questions liées à l'escroquerie car
s'il ya des groupes qui ont été
condamnés en france des groupes qui ont
été qualifiés par ailleurs 2 sec
ils ont été qualifiés
souvent sous le rapport de l'escroquerie
parce que la dimension de l'argent est
une dimension extrêmement importante est
la question qui peut se poser c'est est
ce que en fait vous avez les moyens ou
pas ou est ce que vous êtes demi dans
une position telle qu'en fait vous
dépensez tellement d'argent que vous
êtes
acculé en quelque sorte et mis dans une
situation extrêmement non seulement de
souffrance mais aussi financière
extrêmement extrêmement difficile mais
on doit être abordée en jeu et une
déprise à nos escapades donc vous
interromps promet on peut être aussi
sous l'emprise du jeu ou de la drogue et
ça coûte aussi beaucoup d'argent il ya
en france des lois contre l'escroquerie
contre l'exercice illégal de la médecine
contre le détournement de mineure contre
la séquestration contre la
non-assistance en peine à personne en
danger contre le viol contre le vol
contre la l'abus de faiblesse contre
l'extorsion contre la mise en danger de
la vie d'autrui pourquoi at on besoin de
modifier sans adresse le droit et la loi
pour lutter contre les sectes
s'il ya un problème d' escroquerie de
vol d'abus de faiblesse etc etc
il suffit d'appliquer la loi pourquoi
est-ce qu'on invente une lutte contre
les sectes pourquoi est ce qu'on a
besoin d'une minute pour faire un
travail que normalement n'importe quel
commissaire de police au juge
d'instruction pourrait faire raphaël
liogier moi je crois que moi je crois
que là vous poser une question une
question centrale c'est ce que je disais
c'est qu' il s' agit il s'agit pas en
réalité de lutter contre les sectes
dangereuses pour l'ordre public ou pour
les individus mais instrumentaliser
cette souffrance en fabriquant de
l'unanimisme politique parce qu'en
réalité il y as au real il ya trois
dimensions qui sont bel et la première
dimension c'est que sont ces sectes qui
serait suppose être dangereuse pour le
public en général ce sont ce que les
sociologues appellent des lmr des
nouveaux mouvements religieux qui sont
étudiées par papa par les sociologues
dans le monde entier on étudie ces
nouveaux mouvements et ses mouvements
les seuils de comprendre cliniquement on
essaie de comprendre sociologiquement
économiquement d'où ils viennent et
c'est il ya des ethnographes qui les
équilibres
ça c'est une première chose dont on
aurait utilisé ses travaux ce qu'on ne
fait pas en réalité
deuxième si on voulait vraiment
comprendre ce qui se passe deuxième
point il à l'instrumentalisation
politique qui court circuite en réalité
la lutte contre les sectes qui serait
vraiment dangereuse et le troisième
point c est ce qu on pourrait mettre une
quelle pourrait être la lutte efficace
moi j'ai proposé quelque chose avait
proposé quelque chose avait fait un
article même dans le monde en 2008 sur
ce sujet qui avait fait beaucoup parler
ou je proposais de d'essayer de monter
un système qui ressemble un peu à ce qui
existe au royaume uni est une forme qui
est à 1 à la london school of economics
of economic pardon qu'est ce qu'il faut
dans cette donne c'est très simple il
met des représentants des familles et
donc des victimes des associations de
victimes
donc on les exclut pas leçon là il
explique qu'elle est leur souffrance
pourquoi etc
il a elle souffre deux des chercheurs et
des sociologues qui discute avec avec
elles qui font participer leurs
recherches à cela et des représentants
aussi de l'état et 6 mai et là on aurait
une vision beaucoup plus réalistes
concrètes qui ne mettrait pas à ce
boisseau les victimes et qui en même
temps relativiserait leurs propos et on
serait capable de lutter de façon
efficace mais l'état français ne veut
pas ça il ne veut pas mettre ce système
en place parce que ils se priveraient de
cette source d' instrumentalisation
politique incroyable c'est elle qui
permet en situation désespérée par
exemple aujourd'hui lorsque tous les
sondages montrent que ça ne va pas très
bien pour le gouvernement de fabriquer
de l'unanimisme parce que tout le monde
est d'accord évidemment puisque les
seuils tout le monde est d'accord pour
que les gens souffrent moins pour que
tout aille mieux etc
mais quand on fait une analyse chimique
précise lorsqu'on utilise des travaux
sociologiques lorsqu'on cible lorsqu on
généralise pas alors à ce moment là
c'est plus pareil on fonctionne plus de
la même manière
l'état français ne veut pas perdre la
main là dessus la preuve j'étais en
partie avec mes étudiants à l'époque à
l'origine du passage de la mills à la
miviludes parce que nous avions
fortement critiqué l'action de la
mission interministérielle de lutte
contre les sectes nous avions
particulier montrer
en créant une fausse secte avec mes
étudiants dans mon séminaire 1 et en
faisant appeler des fausses victimes que
sans enquête
nous étions immédiatement classé dans la
liste des dents dans le dal dans les
groupes dangereux sans qui aucune
enquête sans qu'il n'y ait rien eu voyez
bien qu'on ne peut pas fonctionner comme
ça on avait testé la chose même avec mes
étudiants les plus récalcitrants qui
doutaient de deux de mes analyses qu'il
avait constaté
et c'est pour ça qu'à la suite de ce
scandale progressivement de la multitude
même de ces stores bannes on est passé à
non pas mills memmie ville une mission
interministérielle de lutte et de
vigilance mais seulement vigilance et
contre les dérives sectaires
sauf que la miviludes sous l'action de
par exemple de quelqu'un comme georges
fenech et d'autres c'est est devenu
encore pire il y a eu encore plus
ensuite deux conflits en d'ailleurs il
ya eu même des conflits au sein du
gouvernement entre les ministères de
terrain ministère de l'intérieur
ministère de l'éducation ministère de la
culture qui étaient sur le terrain de
ceux d emprise sectaire théorique et qui
disait qu'il n'y avait pas les remontées
dont parlait l'ami la miviludes la mise
d'abord et puis la miviludes quitter lui
eu à matignon et qui aurait été là pour
produire l'idéologie il ya eu des
conflits très très violent on pense par
exemple à didier leschi qui était
directeur du du bureau central des sept
qui s'est fait littéralement insulter
parce qu'il visait des du point de vue
des témoins de jéhovah là aujourd'hui on
n'a pas la possibilité de les attaquer
violemment pas ce cas pas de problème
pénal parce qu'en fait lorsqu'il y à une
situation comment dire avec d'aider des
jeunes qui sont qui sont fragiles des
enfants qui sont fragiles et qu'il faut
une transfusion par exemple même si leur
doctrine dit qu'il ne faut pas
transfusion des parents acceptent quand
même donc on n'a pas de remonter donc on
peut pas condamner des gens pour rien
sansan sans objectivité
donc moi je suis pas contre la lutte
pour laisser contre les sectes
dangereuses
je suis pour une fille efficacité réelle
et donc on ne peut pas faire confiance à
l'état et au gouvernement pour mettre en
place cette lutte parce que c'est une
lutte qui n'est qu'il est non seulement
idéologique mais en plus inefficace
qu'instrumentaliser les victimes mêmes
qui dans un sens intensifient leurs
souffrances alors charline delporte
vous allez peut-être répondre à ma
question pourquoi est ce que dans le cas
des témoins de jéhovah ou d'autres
qualifié de secte pourquoi on ne se sert
pas des lois existantes les lois contre
l'escroquerie contre la mise en danger
d'autrui contre l'extorsion contre la
séquestration contre eux tout ça il
suffit d'appeler la police
pourquoi est ce qu'on a besoin de la
miviludes ou d'une association comme la
vôtre bien écouté j'ai essayé d'être
clair mais quand on est souvent pris
cher monsieur
et là vous avez raison l'arsenal
juridique existe et il faut appliquer
les lois jusqu'au bout mais quand on
rentre quand on adhère au départ un
mouvements à caractère sectaire quels
qu'ils soient
le mouvement il peut en avoir avec des
fondamentalistes ou des gens qui voient
là il peut y avoir comme vous dites les
témoins de jéhovah brouilly sont dans
les fondamentalistes le bien le mal si
tu fais du biac avec jéhovah si tu fais
du mal tu es avec s'attend donc vous
pensez bien une fois manipulé
reprogrammé tu fera certainement pas des
choses mal pour aller avec sept ans et
puis bon bref
mais ça peut être aussi les dérives je
dirais à déviance thérapeutique est donc
là aussi une fois qu'on commence ce
processus de manipulation mentale
qu'est ce qu'on sait maintenant est
aujourd'hui qu'il s'agit bien après
d'une dépendance
il ya tout un processus bien sûr de
séduction de conditionnement de
programme de rupture familiale et de
contractualisation pour le groupe par un
leader weng group un groupe qui est
secte un groupe il va on reconnaît qu'il
est sectaire par ses rapports que
j'apprécie beaucoup et j'avoue
sincèrement que quand on parle de
georges fenech de cette manière là c'est
un ami et il restera un ami et je suis
ravi de tout ce qui a fait quand il
était président de la miviludes 1 / donc
ces personnes là
ces personnes là encore heureux qu'ils
étaient l'an 2002 parce que nous sommes
le seul pays en france et en europe
d'avoir créé
l'ami ce départ qui pas rester longtemps
mais après la miviludes et moi je suis
en effet plus partisan pour la dérive
sectaire comme ça ça nous évite de
parler d'eux c'est je laisse ça aux
sociologues des religieux et aux
sociologues tout seul parce que les
sociologues font des belles histoires
mais raconte pas l'arrière boutique
d'effets dommageables des personnes qui
subissent une fois qu'ils sont entrés
qui sont manipulés et bien sûr que là
une fois qu'il s'en sort parce qu'il ya
aussi des sorties d'emprise et bien ces
sorties d'emprise
quelle que soit la sortie d'emprise est
toujours quelque chose très douloureux
ou alors les personnes ils ont une peur
terrible est sous pression encore de
leurs organisations à caractère sectaire
menée par un meneur
le meneur est le leader est un an et
invite un personnage je dirais
manipulateur pervers ainsi que d'autres
je dirais petit souci de psychiatrie je
peux vous assurer que la personne elle
n'a pas du tout envie au départ d'aller
jeu direct vers la police elle vient
vers à 100 comme le nôtre elle va la
mini l'ul mais elle le veut elle doit
surtout comprendre parce que c'est pas
les idiots qui entrent dans ses dérives
sectaires
ce sont des personnes intelligentes
comme vous et moi personne n'est à
l'abri ce sont des gens qui ont envie de
donner un sens à quelque chose
une question sans réponse et les la
partie citron la mauvaise référence et
le mauvais groupe i au malicieux et moi
encore une fois le religieux moi il me
dérange absolument pas on est dans un
pays de la société
donc vous pouvez croire aux soucoupes
volantes à tout ce que vous voulez du
moment que c'est pas contraire aux lois
mais vous le voyez pas quand vous entrez
dans une emprise sectaire ça c'est faux
il faut détecter l'emprise sectaire
alors ensuite y sort et on lui dit vous
allez aller déposer plainte
bah non certainement pas lorsqu'il
aurait les pressions du groupe est déjà
le groupe
jeter dehors parce que il est devenu un
paria donc après il faut les accompagner
leur tendre la main
tout simplement pour qu'ils puissent
petit à petit retrouver sa dignité
d'homme de femme et surtout de
comprendre ce qui lui est arrivé et si
ces fellahs qui sont des faits
dommageables la vie mais tout notre
mission à nous c'est de pouvoir apporter
cette main tendue tendu et de pouvoir
tout simplement leur expliquer alors
ensuite y en a qui vont déposer plainte
mais sincèrement s'il vous plaît y
savent ces sociologues ils sont pas
idiots non pluies sont intelligents que
d'aller déposer plainte
ça demande énormément je dirais
d'énergie et puis bien sûr le mouvement
secteur en question il a un pouvoir
sourd il a des gens à lui il a ce groupe
qui est là et donc forcément il a peur
et vous savez la peur dans l'emprise il
aura la crainte de la fin du monde parce
que c'est souvent ce qu'on dit dans un
gros si tu viens vers moi que tu vas
voir tu vas gagner un paradis quel que
soit le paradis quand tu es dans
l'emprise de déviance thérapeutique j'ai
la meilleure vérité c'est comme ça que
je vais te soigne et ont commis avec des
choses aberrantes aberrante et donc
naturellement vous pensez bien qu'après
forcément forcément ils n'ont pas envie
d'aller
je dirais vers la plate mais ça arrive
là plein quelques fois où quelques
années il dépose plainte parce qu'ils
disent je ne veux pas que d'autres
subissent là donc ils vont à la plage
mais large maintenant mais l'actuel
m'adresse makoun à la cam hadès la
camada sapin est également a été créée
en 2009 et donc ces gens là ils sont là
ce sont des officiers de police qui vont
prendre les plaintes et ne font que le
fait secteur et c'est eux qui dirigent
ces familles ses victimes mais ces
victimes le temps d'avoir été cette
parenthèse dans leur vie parce que moi
le jour où je les retrouve et qu'on
retrouve le sortant parce que notre
mission c'est d'accompagner jusqu'au
bout avec une équipe maintenant en 2010
en 2021
on ne peut plus jouer aux apparences
sorcier moi je suis écoutant je ne suis
ni psychologue ni je dirais juriste mais
ici on a une équipe de professionnels on
a des psychologues on avocat
on a des juristes on a des frères
libanais salim delporte je vous
interromps mais j'ai compris ce que vous
vouliez dire et c'est vrai que toutes
les lois que j'ai énuméré il ya des lois
contre tout sauf contre une chose qui
s'appelle l'emprise et l'emprise c'est
une notion qui devient de plus en plus
importante dans le discours actuel
puisque on entend de plus en plus des
femmes et des hommes aussi invoqué
l'emprise sous laquelle il était auquel
il était sujet pendant qu'ils se sont
fait violer et et qui ont mis beaucoup
de temps comme vous venez de le décrire
pour pouvoir penser plainte pour pouvoir
en parler parce que disent-ils ils
étaient sous emprise
est ce que est ce que anne morelli là
est ce que la piste de l'emprise qui
serait la caractéristique de l'ordre de
la grille inspecteur est ce que est ce
que vous l'acceptez 7
c'est bien c'est tout nous rassurer
parce que moi j'ai été l'objet d'une
manipulation mentale et d'une emprise
qui a été tel que aujourd'hui toute
vieille que je suis je peux encore vous
dit je crois en un seul dieu créateur du
ciel et de la terre et en jésus-christ
son fils unique notre seigneur qui est
né du saint-esprit et c'est donc on m' a
martelé un certain nombre de choses
absurdes
parce que le le rapport donné à madame
des repas est un rapport où on parle de
de gens qui font croire des absurdités
bien sûr toutes les religions font
croire des absurdités et elles ont droit
moi je crois que les gens ont droit de
croire avec conneries et des conneries
du genre après la mort
ma vieille carcasse va ressusciter ou
bien il ya un enfer pour les méchants et
un paradis pour les gens les bons
et puis les tout le monde a le droit de
croire aussi à des choses merveilleuses
on abusent de la crédulité des gens mais
dans toutes les religions il a vu elle a
fait de même
morelli
avec leurs éléments visuels c'est parce
qu'elle vous dit charline delporte elle
vous dit en gros que l'emprise c'est
quand quelqu'un s'est fait violer et qui
continue de coucher avec son violeur et
qui portent pas vrai que son violeur
cessent alors oui mais non on ne parle
pas toujours de viol heureusement nano
regard triste mais pas d'or
c'est une métaphore que l'envahissement
rares et il est évident que la crédulité
on n'en abusent de la crédulité
savez-vous qu'au début de la crise qu
vie nous avons à bruxelles trois prêtres
intégristes qui sont montés sur l'église
sainte catherine au centre de bruxelles
avec un goupillon et qui ont béni la
ville de bruxelles pour qu'elles ne
soient pas frappés par l'épidémie
alors c'est quoi ça mais c'est profiter
de la crédulité des gens mais s'il ya
des imbéciles qui les croient grand pis
pour eux c'est le roa ne croit à des
bêtises et même à la virginité de marie
et tout ce que vous voulez c'est leur
droit et dans les dites secte
il ya des gens qui croient à des faits
cnous aussi et c'est leur droit après
tout alors une question pour arnaud
esquerre parce que l'émission se termine
ok il ya un problème de manipulation
mentale
il ya un problème d'emprise vous avez
écrit un livre d'ailleurs qui s'intitule
la manipulation mentale
je veux bien qu'on parle de manipulation
mentale quand on parle de des témoins de
jéhovah ou de la secte saugues à kayes
mais quand on parle des manifs scully
nist des survivalistes de qua none même
qui est un groupe complotistes pro trump
qui est sur la liste des sectes dont
marlène schiappa veut désormais
s'occuper quand on parle des crudivore
où ils ont pris jouer l'année mais dit
pulation mentale will gourous visés très
très brièvement d'abord il ya dans le
droit on a introduit au début des années
2000 la notion de sujétion psychologique
donc ça existe simplement c'est dans
l'abus dans l'article 223 de 15 2 du
code pénal
simplement en fait cette notion de
sujétion psychologique
qui était celle en fait de manipulations
mentales ou d'emprise elle est
extrêmement difficile à appliquer pour
les juges parce que il faut trouver des
critères pour la déterminer or c'est
extrêmement compliqué de d'appliquer ou
de déterminer ce qu'est une solution
c'est psychologique c'est pour ça qu'on
fait les juges préfèrent utiliser par
exemple l'escroquerie qui est plus
facile à caractériser donc le droit a
été psychologie c'est vous avez tout à
fait raison
vous connaissez bien cette question avec
l'idée de placer au centre la question
du consentement donc effectivement les
sujets sont sont liées sur ce qui est de
la manipulation mentale elle même et je
crois que l'intervention au début de de
la dola delà de la de la représentante
de l'association des des proches ou des
victimes de sectes
l'aladi c'est à dire qu'est ce que ce
qu'est ce qu'on comptait ce qu'on dit
qu'une personne est manipulée or en fait
on le dit en général ou bien après coup
ou bien ce sont des proches qui le
disent il faut désigner en fait des
changements de la vie quotidienne delà
de la personne elle se comporte plus de
la même manière il faut trouver
quelqu'un en fait à qui on attribue ces
changements et donc c'est comme ça que
ça se comme ça que ça se sache se
caractérise mais évidemment la personne
quant à elle décide en fait de d'en
faire un choix de vie qui est le sien
même si c'est un choix de vie
minoritaire elle à dire maintenant je ne
suis pas manipulée
le mans j'ai choisi une vie différente
qui n'est plus la vie en fait qui ce qui
est celle et après les gens peuvent
changer
on n'a pas beaucoup parlé en fait de là
on a des sorties de sac
il ya des gens qui passent en fait il
faut voir que c'est des milieux qui
peuvent être très composite
vous pouvez à la fois être dans un
groupe il restait deux ans ne pas être
complètement impliqué dedans sortir elle
vous intéresser à des thérapies
alternatives etc
et c'est tout ça en fait cet univers là
en fait dont on parle alors dernier mot
au rafale yeux j'ai ouï mais moi je
voulais dire je ne suis pas contre la
lutte contre les sectes dangereuses pour
l'ordre public et des individus mais je
ne crois pas que la miviludes en
particulier et le chalet dire l'emprise
de l'état puisqu'on parle d'emprise et
améliorer quoi que ce soit sur ce sujet
c'est à dire cette année c'est une sorte
d' esbroufe
lol qu'il y ait des associations de
défense
deux victimes qui accompagne les gens
qu'il y ait des des numéros de téléphone
et puis qu'ensuite on les accompagne on
les aide et c'est le rôle des
associations et c'est très bien c'est
pas un problème mais le problème avec la
question des sexes était un phénomène
tellement flou tellement nébuleux
totalement insaisissables qu'à un moment
donné une ministre malienne chat par
email vous dis on va mettre en place un
certain nombre de choses au cambout lié
tout à l'heure on va faire une loi
on va créer toute une série de mesures
et deux ans après elle arrive ou un an
après l'art il a dit ça s'est amélioré
il y en à moi ça va mieux etc
mais comme on n'a aucun indicateurs
réels de est-ce que ça va vraiment mieux
ou pas mieux mais on est obligé de le
croire donc il ya quelque chose aussi de
secteurs dans cette façon de justifier
la lutte contre les sectes si vous
voulez c'est ça moi que je que je récuse
c'est pas en tant que telle fête qui est
des gens qui souffrent qu'il faut qu'ils
aient des associations qui les suit et
sait c'est que même c'est inefficace et
ça court circuite la vraie lutte qui
pourrait exister contre les sectes
dangereuses collations salées une belle
porte
la ministre a annoncé 140 mille
personnes dont 90 mille enfants victimes
de ces 500 secte
comment elle obtient chiffres rien que
les témoins de jéhovah ces deux cent
mille personnes en france
donc je pense que si on enlevait les
témoins de jéhovah on trouverait
sûrement pas 90 mille enfants victimes
des masculinistes ou ou des shows l'y
aider si cher monsieur vous trouveriez
comme ça il ya deux cent mille témoins
de jéhovah en france je suis pas à moi
c'est vous qui le dites moi par contre
ce que je peux voir cg aujourd'hui 20%
de plus dans les actions de
l'association
j'accompagne ici 250 personnes qu'ils
ont tous je dirais les mêmes
caractéristiques n'est pas le même
mouvement
c'est à dire d'accompagner parce qu'ils
ont tous été victimes d'un mouvement à
caractère sectaire d'une emprise
je dirai au niveau de tout ce qui est
thérapeutique se doter la pratique et
autres tout à l'heure je disais ben oui
mais comment on peut rentrer en emprise
quand on est quand on mange plus comment
je crus et bien il ya tout un processus
également et qui après vous mangez plus
du tout et c'est là où ça peut être
grave pour la personne et l'individu et
je reviens moi mais dommage c'est à dire
que à partir du moment où il ya un
changement de comportement chez la
personne qui avant était bien dans ses
baskets et tout à coup ce changement se
fait avec un à l'apparition d'un leader
d'un groupe d'amis ni groupe parce
qu'avec la personne maintenant vous
pouvez créer votre blog et j'ai oublié
de dire que les réseaux sociaux étaient
formidables aujourd'hui oh très
possible au plus c'est trop vrai pour
être vrai et bien à ce moment-là vous
passez je dirais dans des pratiques qui
ne sont pas les votes on vous flanque
après ta pensée qui n'est pas le nôtre
et on vous enlève votre liberté votre
dignité vous entrez en dépendance et
dans une dépendance qui est celle d'une
emprise caractérisée avec ces critères
de dangerosité qu'on a maintenant depuis
tant d'années et qu'ils ont été faits et
que je suis aujourd'hui parce que je
suis moi le plan aujourd'hui qui est
celui de notre ministre délégué marlène
schiappa et je crois qu'elle va avoir
beaucoup de
l'eau et je vois pas ce qu'on va faire
derrière ça notre moi je vous savez je
ne cherche pas à savoir si la politique
mon centre et un confessionnelle et
apolitique
donc quand j'entends madame la
sociologue dit qu'il y en a un qui a
béni toul à bruxelles
est-ce que vous allez d'effets
dommageables chère madame vous avez des
faits dommageables
ils sont à vie eh bien je serais
d'accord de vous accueillir j'ai une
main tendue pour vous et je vous aiderai
à retrouver une certaine dignité et à
pouvoir ne plus souffrir de ce que vous
avez vécu derrière sa dernière une
emprise sectaire
parce que derrière c'est vraiment je
dirais l'arrière boutique est dangereuse
il ya des viols il y a de tout ce que
l'on veut mais je peux vous assurer que
ce secteur c'est pas quelque chose on
doit prendre à la légère surtout en 2021
voilà un terrain charlie dalin delepaul
je vous interromps parce que l'émission
est terminée je vous remercie tous les
quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]